[Music]
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall had The
Spectator in London today I'm joined by
sirab Amari a founder and editor of
Compact magazine contributing editor of
the American conservative author of the
books the new Philistines a critique of
how identity politics have corrupted the
Arts from fire by water about his
conversion to Catholicism and The
Unbroken threat discovering the wisdom
of tradition in an age of chaos but
crucially surab is or was the editor of
the New York Post when the Biden laptop
story broke which of course with the
recent
Twitter files exposed by Matt Tybee and
Barry Weiss is
back as a number one story in the world
so rad thank you so much for taking the
time to speak with me today thanks for
having me Winston
um so
I want to get into the Twitter files but
uh first of all I want to ask you about
the laptop story so
you broke the laptop story before the
presidential election in I think
November 2020 it was in October 2020 but
how did the laptop get from a Delaware
computer service shop into your hands
so I should start by noting I was the
comment editor of the post at the time
so I was not involved in the reporting
of of the uh Hunter files laptop story
um in the U.S there's this weird Chinese
wall between news and opinion so the
opinion sits on one side news on the
other so I was
um of course running our op-ed pages and
so forth
um but obviously we followed it like
everyone else at the paper
I woke up at five in the morning on
October 14th the day that uh the first
Hunter file story appeared on our front
page
um at the post and so that I I
encountered it alongside everyone else I
didn't know that my news colleagues were
Brewing this thing as it were the night
before
um and I thought it was a great scoop we
can go into what that story actually had
uncovered
um but what was remarkable about it and
this goes to your question is how
transparent the post was in terms of the
sourcing of the material over the
preceding four years there had been this
mountain of typically anti-trump stories
which the sourcing was based on
Anonymous sources the dog catcher of the
uncle of a senior Administration
official told so and so this was not the
case the post laid out how we had gotten
hold of this the sort of the Providence
of this material
um and briefly uh Hunter Biden dropped
off his laptop at a Delaware repair shop
Delaware happens to be the home state of
the bidens if you drive through it
you'll see a gas station that's called
the Joseph R Biden gas station and then
rest stop so that's how Associated they
are with Delaware he had dropped it off
there forgotten it for more than 90 days
and I guess under Delaware state law
something called constructive ownership
which means if you abandon something
like that and you don't pay for your
repairs the laptop shop repair shop
takes ownership of the laptop the laptop
owner looked into the stuff that was in
there
and noticed there were some questionable
material salacious material and alerted
the FBI and they
sequestered the laptop but he made a
copy a private copy before turning it
over to the to the authorities
um and he happened to be a republican so
he you know through the networks he knew
eventually he got it into the hands of
Rudy giuliani's lawyer Rudy Giuliani the
former New York city mayor of course a
um friend of the Trump Camp
um Rudy then tells Steve Bannon another
Trump conciliary
um and word gets out uh from bat from
Bannon to the post we we learned that
this laptop existed and we petitioned
Bannon to to let us have a copy of the
hard drive and we did and so we were
from the very beginning from the very
first story The Post had been very
transparent about how we got hold of
this material and we said that the
sourcing was partisan right we said that
we got this from the Trump Camp
essentially but you know again that's a
lot more credible than the kind of
anonymous sourcing anonymously sourced
stories which collapsed under subsequent
factual scrutiny this story did not
collapse under factual scrutiny it was
partisanly sourced but we were open we
trusted the intelligence of our readers
to take that into account alongside the
totality of the other material that was
put forward in the story and make their
own judgment about it
so that's how it was it was a longer
answer to your question but that's how
we came upon well there's other stories
for example be Russian interference in
the 2016 election is that another
example or oh correct there's so many of
them so for example uh there was a story
in McClatchy which is a newspaper chain
in the United States that said that um
Michael Cohen then Trump's lawyer had um
met had gone to Prague and met with you
know his FSB handlers or Russian
handlers or something like that
utterly debunked subsequently by these
special counsel reports into so-called
Russia collusion a story about Trump's
suborning perjury from my uh from
Michael Cohen uh these all appeared in
mainstream media Outlets the whole uh
dossier the the the the put together by
Brit as it happens Christopher Steele
that Steele dossier about Moscow PP
tapes etc etc which subsequently got
debunked
um those were all dubious much more
dubiously sourced than this one and they
all as I said these are those examples
are ones stories that they everyone now
acknowledges were false or incorrect
stories that's not the case with uh the
the post's hunter files reporting so you
get the laptop are you do you aware in
advance of what's on the laptop are you
told by these people Giuliani Bannon
what's on there or does the New York
Post then go into the laptop and do
their own sort of exploring so this is
the part where the limits of my purview
become relevant uh as I said I was the
opinion editor so I was running
um columns and so forth and so I don't
precisely know my understanding is there
was some
hint given as to what was in there that
was newsworthy and interesting and then
the post did its own subsequent
reporting to look at that material and
verify so the first story as you'll
recall involved a an email showing or
suggesting that Hunter had set up a
meeting between
Executives from a Ukrainian energy firm
called barisma which was then paying him
83 000 a month to serve on their board
even though uh as far as I know Hunter
has no special expertise in Eastern
European energy Affairs or or what have
you doesn't even speak Russian or
Ukrainian
um between Executives from barisma on
one hand and his then uh vice president
father who was the Obama
administration's Point man on Ukraine
because that was in 2014. the meeting I
believe was in 2015.
and
um so that was the that was the basis of
the first story and so the interesting
part in this is
um the Biden Camp has never denied that
aspect of the story in fact they haven't
denied any of it the first thing you
would do if someone says hey here's a
laptop here's an email uh we found it
suggests this and that what do you do
you say if if it's not the case you say
that was not my laptop
yeah they never did that through this
entire affair because then I mean it's
very obvious but on the other hand
there's not a direct link to Joe Biden
it just says 10 for the big guy so
there's not explicitly singling out Joe
Biden as complicit so that was a
subsequent story which appeared in the
post the following day and it involved
um
Hunters Chinese dealings Hunter had also
been involved in uh business
negotiations with a
Communist Party linked uh firm as any
any important Chinese firm will be
coming he's party linked and they were
talking about allocation of
um uh
profits and there was an email that said
10 held for the big big guy subsequently
a hunter's business deal partner in that
Affair a guy named bobolinski uh
came forward a lifelong Democrat by the
way came forward and a former
intelligent Naval intelligence officer
came forward and said that that 10
percent was understood to refer to Joe
Biden so that's a different uh the 10
thing is China related Hunter was a busy
man as you can tell
um the the Ukrainian one is is just
unquestionable because there's a gap in
in Biden's schedule that day when this
business this meeting was supposed to
have taken place and there are emails
that suggest that the meetings took
place because barisma executives are
thanking Hunter
um
for setting it up so and yet actually I
should note that still now Wikipedia
says the Biden uh Ukraine is a it's a
conspiracy theory a baseless conspiracy
theory but actually it's not baseless
this is the basis of it this is
basis on what I mean like I said uh
I mean is it outrageous that Wikipedia
um has that claim I hadn't looked at
that that's that's unbelievably which is
why you shouldn't rely on Wikipedia for
the most part because it's randomly
edited by anyone can go on and edit it
there's no authoritative Dimension to it
um no I mean the the hunt the hunter
Camp did not deny that this was Hunter's
laptop in fact
a few months later he did an interview
with uh one of the networks in the U.S
and he was asked is this your laptop he
said well it certainly could be
um and the Biden the Biden White House
I'm sorry the Biden campaign never
denied that then Vice President Biden
had had this meeting
um so this is not baseless I mean the
the
and then more recently uh
the network the networks the US networks
have done their own verification of the
independent verification of the hard
drive and indeed verified that uh this
was a this was an authentic hard drive
um so the idea that this that the
material on there is
you know fake is just it does not
withstand scrutiny go ahead well uh the
other half of the story within the
laptop is all these pictures and videos
of Hunter Biden with prostitutes naked
sexually lured uh content uh which I I
would suppose that had that come out
could even have worked to Joe Biden's
Advantage because you'd say oh I've got
a son who's got addiction problems so
they sort of ignore that but the so the
crucial part is those links between Joe
Biden and Ukrainian barisma company and
the Chinese energy firm that's the
that's the correct one and I would note
that the posts could have published a
lot more of the salacious material
[Music]
um
a lot more where that came from and some
of it subsequently came out in other
outlets
um
we at the post I think the philosophy
was
revealed just enough to authenticate or
give Credence to the meaty stuff about
Ukraine and China but don't make it
about this man's personal struggle so we
I think very judiciously the post didn't
flood the internet
with photos of Hunter with
um in some cases with for example
prostitutes who looked very young and
they were fought you know I think there
was some concern that they might be
underage subsequently I think they're
not the case I think he just has a
preference for very young looking women
of legal age but at any rate we did not
flood the internet with that material
others subsequently did just enough to
say hey this comes from a tranche of
material that's all connected in in
other words the the emails
couldn't have come from a source other
than what we say they are because
there's also this other material so then
what happened you put you run the story
taught me through the next days and and
what happened with Twitter
so yeah this is the part I'm more
familiar with because I was on the front
end of it
um so yeah I looked up the story at five
in the morning I thought wow what a
scoop this is impressive good job to my
colleagues who did this
okay a few hours go by the story is
gaining traction on on Twitter and
Facebook everyone's sharing it and then
as I recall at about 10 or 11 in the
morning Eastern Time a Facebook
communication staffer Facebook not
Twitter yet Facebook communication staff
her name Andy Stone
who on his bio listed that before
working for Facebook he worked for the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee
uh for Senator Barbara Boxer a Democrat
of California and other Democratic
operations
he Andy Stone said I will deliberately
not share the New York Post story but I
will just say I'm slightly paraphrasing
that it raises serious fact-checking
questions and it qualifies for Facebook
fact checking and in the meanwhile we
are reducing circulation on the story on
our platform now
over the again like I said over the
previous four years there had been a
mountain of stories that collapsed under
factual scrutiny sometimes within a
matter of 12 hours so for example
BuzzFeed uh as I mentioned ran a story
that said Trump had stillborn perjury
from his uh lawyer Michael Cohen uh
suborning perjury means you tell someone
you order someone to go lie in this case
to lie under oath in front of Congress
and
um within 12 hours the
uh the former FBI director Robert
Mueller his special counsel who was then
investigating so-called Russia collusion
put out a statement saying this story is
not correct this is false and did
Facebook reduce circulation on that
story no did Twitter ban that story no
but in this case Facebook reduced
circulation and then soon after Andy
Stone statement who again remember Andy
Stone Works for Facebook I noticed you
couldn't post the story online and
people were trying to send it to me
personally
through direct messages
uh saying hey look you know I can't post
this and they couldn't share the story
and direct messages either and I tried
that and I noticed I couldn't share it
so Not only was it banned from from uh
you know the public Pages you couldn't
post it on your wall on on Twitter but
you couldn't also share it in direct
messages
and then uh then Twitter outright
suspended the Twitter account that with
8 million followers of the New York Post
it's worth noting the New York Post is
America's oldest continuously published
Daily Newspaper it was founded by
Alexander Hamilton one of our founding
fathers and yet here it was being
suspended for they said and we'll get
into this I know in a little bit they
said this violates our hacked materials
policy
um
uh then at some point they also said
that it um it's a disclosure of material
not authorized for release by
someone else by the subject of the story
um now this was not hacked material we
insisted it was not hack material the
provenance species is what we said it
was and subsequently of course like I
said U.S Network news confirmed that
this really came from a laptop
this is not hacked material
um and the New York Post is not in the
business of hacking
um so that was the excuse
and so the account was suspended for
about two weeks
we've also published by the way the
following day the Chinese Story the
following day being October 15. the the
story about the Chinese business dealing
that also was banned I remember
distinctly everyone focused on the
Banning of the first story I always try
to remember that they also banned the
subsequent uh China story on Twitter
and a lot of blue check media mainstream
media uh we are the New York Post again
is is part of that ecosystem but a lot
of the others were telling us you know
uh
just delete the story you know just
delete your Tweet so you can get your
account back
but the post didn't because we insisted
that this was not hacked material
um what was going on behind the scenes
at the post was it was it outrage was it
frustration did you in some way expect
this might have happened were you
surprised by what was happening
I mean I see I think the
um I I don't know what the wider
Newsroom thought because I you know uh
it was during the pandemic we all were
working from home uh but I was
definitely talking to people in the
um you know our editor-in-chief because
I report to him
his comment editor
um and the attitude was we're gonna
fight this that you know we we stand by
our story it was confidence in our story
and
um we did and luckily I mean over the
course of those two weeks
uh
the post is has enough resources to put
our case forward we went on TV you know
I did new Fox News hits my colleague
Miranda Devine who's a columnist for us
uh did Fox News hits uh
Congressional hearings were quickly
established Etc
and all that pressure ultimately led to
Facebook relenting for a while by the
way it's worth noting they said okay
we've changed our rules you can post
hacked materials as long as you're not
the party who hacked Facebook or Twitter
apologies Twitter said you can fo you
can post hack materials as long as
you're not the hacker now we insist and
continue to insist and everyone knows
now that this was not hack material to
begin with but they were saying okay
we've changed our policy but go back and
delete your original tweet you can tweet
it again
but
um you know now that you if you tweet it
again you will be uh no longer violating
the original policy because the policy
has been changed but you have to go back
and delete the original tweet so they
were offering us this
and this is where I'm really proud of my
colleagues is that we did not do that
CNN was there was a a anchor at CNN and
Jake Tapper he was he tweeted something
he said why don't you just delete it you
can repost it they've changed their
policy you can just post the exact same
thing but that would have been an
admission of of this story not being
credible about being what we said it was
so we didn't do that and they Twitter at
some point just relented I don't quite
follow why they would want why it was so
important for them to have you delete
the first one and because they would say
that you violated our policy as it stood
back then we've changed the policy go
tweet the go delete the tweet that was
that transgress the original policy but
now that the policies change if you
tweet it again it'll be in compliance
but again this was not hacked material
um I mean there's so many dimensions to
this story
I mentioned you know CNN and some other
outlets the one of the most shameful
Dimensions is the is the um
the refusal of other media Outlets to
come to our side in fact
the vast majority of blue check media
let's say mainstream reporters
journalists
all either cheer the censorship or turn
the other way or can try to condemn the
post rather than standing up for free
speech
NPR which is our equivalent of the BBC
it's a
taxpayer-funded national public radio
put out a statement saying you know we
won't even touch the story because we
don't we don't deal with fake you know
non-story stories
um like I said CNN's just said why don't
you relent why don't you why don't you
back down
um and then you know one or two
journalists who posted the story and
said hey this might be interesting or
something like that had to do these uh
uh you know Maui's style self-criticism
sessions I'm so sorry for having posted
that New York Post story
Etc so at the time what did you think
that was happening do you think this was
to to change the the course of the
election
I mean I think at the time I tweeted
something which got like a hundred
thousand likes and tens of thousands of
retweets and I said something like this
is um
this is a kind of tech totalitarianism
right that in our Century
totalitarianism doesn't look like
uh you know a a torture in a darkened
cell driving a nail under the during a
screw under the nail of a
dissident but rather the fact that a
Silicon Valley Corporation can disappear
from the internet from Bath Slots of the
internet a story that is damaging to the
preferred presidential candidate of the
establishment The Establishment being
not just Silicon Valley but
on a Wall Street Hollywood uh
the professional classes this kind of
the security apparatus they all hated
Trump let's be honest and
the I think the mentality in part was
that somehow Trump had been
illegitimately elected in 2016 there was
this uh and that that social media
platforms had played a role in his
election and therefore this time around
they weren't going to let a story like
this perhaps they were willing to go
much further than they actually did they
weren't going to let him get reelected
and
just to go back sorry to all the media
who lined up on the side of censorship
there was also
um
a statement put out by 50 former
intelligence officials you know the
heads of the CIA Etc that said they had
signed a letter 50 of them that said
although we don't have any evidence this
Hunter laptop story Bears all the
indicia or the Hallmarks of a Russian
disinformation operation
and of course this was first reported by
Natasha Bertrand of Politico and it was
reported like it was gospel
and in other words
50 intelligence officials say this
well what was the relationship between
the intelligence apparatus and and the
media let's say a decade ago two days
decades ago three four decades ago it's
supposed to be an adversarial
relationship right the intelligence
agencies are the least accountable
dimension of American power these are
people who can
you know drone people out of the sky you
know their budgets are all classified
you don't know what they do so that's
why you know journalists some of the
greatest journalists are journalists
have gone against uh these elements of
American power and uncovered wrongdoing
held them accountable brought brought
shed light into areas where
unaccountable power would prefer
darkness that was the historic role of
of American journalism so in this case
50 intelligence officials say this is
Russian disinformation what's the job of
the journalist well it's not to say well
you're wrong sir it that's that wouldn't
be right either but just what you ask
questions so well how do you know what
evidence do you have let me dig into it
that's not what they did how what how
long after that was after you published
the story did that letter come out
easily within the first 48 hours because
uh even though you you saw it stone at
Facebook not mentioning Russian
interference when Zuckerberg went on
Rogan Zuckerberg said that the FBI came
to him saying it was Russian
interference and so that's why Facebook
took the story down
correct this I mean this wouldn't be the
FBI this would be they were all retired
officials 50 so it's just kind of
there's I mean that the fact that these
two elements of the story and there's so
many others suggest this kind of
cross-establishment effort right
corporations blue check media corporate
media
FBI former intelligence officials all
kind of working together
um no but the shameful thing is that you
know you're not when a former spook says
former top spook says
XYZ you're not supposed to say oh yes
sir yes sir Mr Brennan yes it's XYZ
you're supposed to ask questions that
none of them did they reported that this
this letter as gospel which then helped
further legitimate the censorship do you
think it changed the course of the
election
I mean there are there are
polls out there that suggest that X
marginal share that varies by state but
x-marginal share of of people who voted
for Biden might have reconsidered their
votes had they encountered this story
which they didn't
um and
um you know in just like here in Britain
where
really the an election is turns on the
outcome of marginal districts right
exactly is same in the same in the
United States right so we can't say for
sure because the causality is so
complicated but
um undoubtedly some marginal share
voters and potentially a decisive margin
um might have voted differently had they
encountered this material so so now
since then Elon Musk has bought Twitter
and over the last few days we've had
journalist Matt Tybee and Barry Weiss
revealing in the Twitter files what was
happening behind the scenes and the
first tranche of information from the
Twitter files from taibi was
specifically about the suppression of
the New York Post story
how do you feel about them
I mean it's a kind of uh cold anger now
it's been two years
um but it's just confirmation of what we
knew the part that's very interesting
and it could frame our entire
conversation that you and I are having
right now is over the Hacked materials
claim
the most interesting aspect of the first
trench which was handed by musk to taibi
was the internal deliberations of senior
Twitter Executives over the hunter Biden
story
and internally
they all consider the Hacked materials
argument to be risible none of them they
knew on the inside that it doesn't hold
water so you hear you you can read them
internally saying
I don't think this will hold up this is
hours after they've called they've
called it hacked materials and yet days
and days went by and Twitter did not
relent initially on this hacked
materials they knew internally that this
wasn't hacked material that the the
calling this hacked material
makes no sense and
um but that's great Vindication that is
great Vindication is it because it's
sort of when you read it it sort of
seems like they're desperate but they
don't have a better option than citing
hacked material correct yeah right um so
uh I think someone told tavey sorry
someone one of them said you know we all
knew it was wrong but nobody had the
guts to say no to this
I used to pro uh okay so the Twitter
Files come out and in some sense we knew
it you certainly it seems like you knew
what was this was just confirmation of
what you already thought some people are
saying that this is a nothing Burger
quote uh this new infiltrator defiles
other people are saying that this is the
biggest political Scandal since
Watergate
what's new about what we've learned from
the Twitter files and is it serious or
is it nothing Burger
I mean I think it's extremely serious
and I I don't want to just focus on the
outcome of the 2020 election although
that's no small beer right
um the possibility that
um
a story that was damaging to one of the
two major party candidates was
suppressed by a combination of
um big Tech
mainstream media
the intelligence apparatus former and
current officials potentially
um
that's a that's a huge story
I mean the deeper story I think and the
um
the one that makes it much more
interesting for me is
the picture that it gives us of
privatized censorship and privatize
repression and tyranny in the United
States that is
um
if you
if you're an American you're used to
thinking of
government and the public sphere
as where repression happens and where we
need checks and balances
um that's a typical American mentality
we are much less I think it's an
anglo-american mentality we are much
less Vigilant against an alert to the
possibility of private coercion of
private
uh whether it's
outsourced by government or whether it's
just private act which I think in a way
it's worse if it's just private actors
acting on their own initiative
um the idea that journalism can be
repressed by
essentially as you saw these
unaccountable
Tech Bros yeah
um but it's chilling it is outsourced by
government and in my opinion with
Section 230 C which and I'll I'll read
it here the Good Samaritan provision
which protects platforms from liability
for quote any action
voluntarily taken in good faith to
restrict access to or availability of
material that the provider or user
considers to be obscene lewd lascivious
filthy excessively violent harassing or
otherwise objectionable whether or not
such material is constitutionally
protected so
it is outsourced by the government
indeed for big Tech and the like to
censor well it's worth getting into that
law we need section 230 reform and you
know I've I've been going on Fox the
past few days a couple of times
you know people are saying much like you
people are like well two years later all
this has come out you know where do you
stand on it now and what I always say is
it's not enough to say well thank God
for Elon Musk for shedding light on this
because ultimately we shouldn't be at
the mercy of one billionaire however
pro-free speech he might be because this
is a structural problem and one of the
structural public policy elements in
this is precisely that piece of
legislation you're at
section 230. it's worth asking section
230 of what it's section 230 of a 1996
law called the communications decency
act and
so note it was enacted in 1996 before
there was before Twitter was a glimmer
in Mark Zuckerberg's eye before Facebook
Facebook
or before Twitter had been invented this
is before the age of social media it
governed
um this online bulletin boards right
on a bulletin board you provide the
platform and then different people can
come in and say have their say now
if section 230 didn't exist
I could come in and post something
um libelous I'd defame you on and not
only would you be able to sue me for
defaming you but you could sue the
bulletin board which provided the
platform right it's a publisher in a way
just like an if the spectator publishes
libelous material not only is the author
of the piece liable for that but but the
spectator itself can be sued under
common law defamation or libel laws
section 230 came in in the early days of
the intranet with the idea being that we
want bulletin boards to exist and people
to be able to have their say but we want
the
providers of the platform to be able to
take action against child pornography
against violent threats notice the kind
of material that you let off it's like
lascivious uh you know lewd obscene etc
etc we want them to be able to act like
that act like a publisher so they choose
which things can go and which things
cannot go online
without without being subject to a
traditional Publisher's liability so
uh
then in the in the the decade that
followed Twitter emerged Facebook
emerged and they they were governed by
the communications decency act in the
sense that they were allowed and even
encouraged to interdict
genuinely bad material right we don't
want child porn
without
um without bearing any of the
traditional Publishers liabilities
now it's that law has been completely
perverted and abused by big Tech and yet
they insist on maintaining the current
regime how has it been perverted if you
go on Twitter you can find immediately
the most extreme pornography easily it's
everywhere and sometimes you
accidentally may come upon it
or they don't act on it but they use it
to act like a publisher for example by
censoring the the hunter files story
um and they're allowed to do that by
under Section 230 and they spend
millions of dollars every year big Tech
does lobbying Washington to maintain the
current regime which allows them to act
like if you go on like Facebook Facebook
almost has its own world view it
encourages you to support certain
political causes and just it it can
certainly decirculate certain stories as
they did with the hunter files and yet
it it's it's not treated the way The
Spectator is it's not treated the way
the New York Post is it has the special
status
and I think that needs to change I think
there has to be a reform if they want to
act like Publishers then they should
bear a traditional Publisher's
liabilities meaning section 230 has to
be drastically Rewritten or abrogated or
uh at any rate deeply reformed do you
think reformed to mirror there's the
same standards for other
newspapers Etc have media other media
Outlets to match what they the laws the
requirements they have well and then and
then I think the um I mean there would
be enormous pressure on them to they
would probably seek to have to censor
more right because then they're and in
anything that appears on their platforms
uh could potentially lead to liability
for them which wouldn't be very
practical which wouldn't be very
practical but the threat of that right
should should be uh used to get them to
agree to what I call well not what I
call it would is called under U.S law
common carrier rules right
common carrier rules are what govern
your relationship with your like
landline phone company or your or the
train come train that you take or your
aircraft airplane for the most part
these can't discriminate against you
based on your political views
right because we recognize them as this
kind of common good people need to be
able to make calls people need to be
able to get on trains Etc
and so
um they basically have to let anyone use
their services and I think you know
something like that is a common carrier
and then of course you know uh a common
carrier still has a right to interdict
like genuinely dangerous material and so
forth
um
porn child porn Etc
but not but not political content so uh
as as a conservative writer uh were you
surprised at all to see how through the
Twitter files how it was conservative
voices that were silenced and that
Progressive voices on the other side
didn't face the same sort of uh
um
uh treatment
not at all
um
you know there it's worth noting there
are there are some
some lefties who aren't like Democrat
lefties right get censored as well
or leftists who oppose
um lockdown regimes and so forth for for
left-wing reasons have also faced this
kind of thing but it's absolutely true
that overwhelmingly it's like populist
conservative types who get uh who face
the sharp end of this kind of censorship
and
um
so I'm not surprised at all because I
think I I I'm fairly confident I
experienced it right in a sense that I
so
you know I had at some point I hit like
130
000 followers on Twitter
and
um
for about a year after January 6 it
would not go up I would have tweets that
would go viral I would get lots of new
followers but somehow I would stay so
whether or not that means my account was
being throttled or lots of my right of
Center followers were being banned or
Shadow banned or at any rate suspended
from the platform so I mean and you saw
it and I knew tons and tons of people
who were either themselves banned or or
could tell you that they've been
throttled in a way that's not natural
their follower account wasn't Rising
this is to show shadowbun and this is
what Barry Weiss has just revealed in
the second tranche was that shadow
Banning was very much happening and and
um it's not called China it's called
visibility uh well I've forgotten uh
exactly visibility reduction or whatever
something like that some euphemism which
is exactly the same uh thing so so but
we sort of knew that that was happening
we saw it yeah we all experienced it you
experienced it yeah so it's no surprise
really that now we've been yeah proved
right yes is there any any
Vindication for you or is again if this
this is we already knew this this isn't
this is a non-story it's it's nice to
see the internal deliberations that
reveal and this mechanism they use I
mean there's like a you know you pull up
what barrier revealed is sort of the the
console that you see if you're a a
manager at Twitter and you can pull up
an account and you can apply various
restrictions on it that that restrict
its um
its ability to proliferate or gain
followers and so to see it to be that as
straightforward as that that someone can
click something and your account doesn't
grow in followers or a certain tweet
um
becomes more hidden and more difficult
to find and therefore doesn't
um go viral to see how simple it all is
it's pretty pretty remarkable
um and also I mean this raises a kind of
a
a legal question for current or former
Executives at Twitter is that they
testified under oath
that this wasn't happening before
Congress
and so this raises questions of did they
did they perjure themselves
um
uh
what what what sort of uh
accountability can con and can Congress
pursue for for being lied to by Twitter
Executives who said that there isn't
partisan
Shadow Banning or what have you all of
this gives the impression that I mean
again we sort of already knew this but
there's a real free speech problem in
America and given that the first
amendment in the Bill of Rights it's
it's so foundational to
American philosophy and and everything
that's great and important about America
and was founded on
do you do you agree with that that
there's a free speech problem or and and
how how deep a problem is it if so
I mean look it's it's
obscene quite literally obscene that
you can have
the vileless pornography on Twitter
but questioning
lockdowns as Dr J batarchaya did
one of the founding signatories of the
Great Barrington declaration Stanford
physician I've met him at just an
eminently
sane sober deeply educated thoughtful
guy who early on said hey lockdowns may
not work be worth it they may damage
children's future and his account was
one of the ones that we saw through the
Barry Weiss tranche was one of the ones
that had been throttled by Twitter
executives
so his voice
um doesn't get heard but you can get any
any amount of pornography which was not
part of the original
um conception of free speech in the
United States right in other words for
most of its history the United States
had obscenity laws and even before there
was a United States colonial America had
obscenity laws common law obscenity laws
and then subsequently a federal
obscenity law and those are still on the
books yet they're not enforced for
decades and decades centuries no one
thought that that was protected speech
that's fine
but questioning lockdowns
Gets You throttled by a
kind of privatized censorship apparatus
that's a huge crisis of course it's a
huge crisis it's a crisis in two ways
the one I think that's in a way less
dangerous
is the one where okay speech is getting
throttled Ordinary People don't get to
be heard that's really huge by the way
that's a bad thing
but the more
dangerous type of uh consequence from
this
that's one where you know Malcolm cune
recently argued this point in compact uh
our magazine
um
it's that Elites themselves
are barred from
accessing the full range of information
that they need to make decisions right
Twitter is where Elite consensus forms
it's where journalists government Etc go
to see what they're they're all thinking
to communicate with each other in a way
and
um
if they're creating a kind of bubble
where dissident views aren't coming in
they make bad decisions as indeed they
did with lockdowns they instead of
listening to Jay batarchaya they banned
him well but that's not Elites doing
that that's because the elites still
have access to that information if they
want if wanted it's that the general
public don't have access to that well no
I mean I think there is a kind of um
Elite consensus formation that happens
on Twitter where they're told you know
what they're allowed to
um
what they're allowed to think what
they're um
what's considered you know
an opinion that just shouldn't be heard
at all
um you know Elites are just as much
susceptible to
kind of cultural pressure as Ordinary
People and cultural pressure is often
undergirded by and stands on sort of
normative
um kind of but by rules right the norms
and rules that are imposed on a certain
platform
um help shape the kind of cultural
socially acceptable thought sure so who
are the elites in this hypothesis
I mean it's it's the American ruling
class it's uh
large owners of uh of capital the
professionals who service their assets
it's uh the National Security apparatus
it's
um
the media for sure Tech Hollywood now
there are individuals who go against the
grain in this case like someone like
Elon Musk
um and you know thank God for that but
there is you know there is a kind of
consensus that's that's form and it used
to be honest they used to be uh it used
to happen in um traditional media right
there used to be you know the New York
Times The Wall Street Journal
Network news and that's where this kind
of so we shouldn't have illusions that
there was like an earlier age in which
um this kind of process didn't happen
um interestingly enough in in Democracy
in America by De tocaville he does
describe how some ideas are totally
acceptable to discuss and then at
certain point they become unacceptable
to discuss when when a consensus is
formed and so it's it's discussion on
those topics becomes impossible so this
is actually a very old ancient human
phenomenon sure sure I think that what's
chilling or
um
knew about it in a democracy is that
um the norm setting including Norm
setting for Elites themselves is done by
unaccountable private entities in other
words there it's not subject to
democratic give and take it's not
subject to community pressure
um but rather is done in corporate
boardrooms or in uh managerial settings
of of lawyers sitting down with uh you
know Tech Executives Etc who are all in
their own little bubbles their own
little have their own little group think
correct yeah um that's the sort of new
dimension of this which is a little bit
is different than you know I think the
small Puritan town you know
in in New England that that you know
tocqueville might have uh encountered
here so aside from uh someone like Elon
Musk saving Twitter and section 2013
being reformed uh what's a hopeful way
out of this like what can we actually
hope or what's a positive
way out of this mess or rather are you
hopeful that we can get out of this mess
um yes so
um
the situation that we're entering is not
entirely different than the conditions
um economic conditions political
economic conditions that prevailed in
the United States
in the 19th century
uh up through the Great Depression and
not much different arguably across the
across much of the wider West as well
great
vast concentrations of private power
um where they are not this power is not
countervailed from Below
and then with the birth of
um
social democracy or not I shouldn't say
the birth the the
um
the rise of social democracy as a
political force and Christian democracy
in Europe
and in a slightly muted form with a new
deal in the United States
we realized that in many markets uh
there are there are only so many actors
there are only a few actors which means
that the old kind of free market recipe
for fixing these markets coercion in
these markets doesn't work right in pure
laissez-faire Theory which is largely
based in a pre-industrial right uh
context it's the models are drawn from a
pre-industrial context
the sheer existence of many many actors
by many many buyers many many sellers in
any Market means that no one not one of
them can have too much coercive power
but Post in the austrial age when you
have uh Network Industries or where you
have um Industries uh of great scale
there really are only
just a few players in any market right
so in the social let's forget about
social media with you know
um car manufacturers there are only so
many you can for the most part you can't
you know start a mom and pop uh uh car
manufacturer as my friend Michael
Michael Lynn points out there or return
to social media there's only how many
are there yeah there's two or three
um so that means that the those two or
three
can exercise enormous power they get to
set the price they get to tell their
customers uh you know what's acceptable
and what's not
they get to
um
you know sensor information in the case
of social media and be largely
unaccountable so what was the solution
to this problem that emerged roughly
from 1945 to the 1970s uh in the United
States and in Europe as well was
a model based on the raising up of a
countervailing power of the people who
are subject to this kind of coercion so
in labor markets that means labor trades
unions
in um uh in other areas it may have
meant some Anti-Trust action uh in other
areas that meant government coordinating
with capital and labor to say to set
conditions prices wages Etc so it was a
much more heavily regulated heavily
unionized uh form but sure up in the in
the let's say social media use you
firstly you've had let's say one half
the conservative half so to speak or the
anti-establishment half if you will
constantly standing up saying that that
these there's been a suppression of
voices there's been Shadow banning all
this stuff which we now know is true and
then the other half seem to support the
censorship so where is this yeah
supposedly uh um great question
fight back gonna come from great
question
conservatives
who are subject to this
who are basically facing the business
end of this kind of private coercion are
in many ways the the ones who brought
about the current order
right it was it was the kind of Reagan
Thatcher Revolution that undid I think
and it's a common story so I'm not the
only one arguing that undid the sort of
settlement that prevailed from 1945
through the 70s
um they said no no if we liberate big
business we'll have a kind of a
flowering of of of uh an economic
flowering and also a kind of a Freer
Society
blind as they were I I would argue to
the possibility of private coercion
um and so now that they're subject to it
uh
I think conservatives are in a position
to recover the wisdom of that earlier
settlement which in the United States
keep in mind it wasn't just the the
Democrats who pushed for the sort of New
Deal consensus it was also Eisenhower
and Nixon did as well Republicans
they recognize that something had
happened to the economy in the 19th
century and up through the depression
that necessitated a solution in which
more people get a say in in the
management of the economy
um and then that wisdom was thrown out
the window the best way to confront woke
sensorious capital
is to
reduce the power of capital as such and
then so you know for example
you're worried about uh censorship of
conservative views the best way is to
just stand against the large
concentrations of power that enable that
kind of uh abuse right so if you're or
you're worried about uh you know Disney
or Google or whatever telling its
employees and consumers to think this
way and that
reducing the sort of aggregate power
these entities have over their suppliers
consumers workers Etc
is the best way that this it's a way not
to make this about the kind of culture
War it's a kind of material way just
reduce the power of the large in general
or or raise up the power of the week to
some degree restore a measure of balance
and then people can fight back much more
easily rather than saying well we're
going to
um you know
we're going to we're going to go after
companies if they say XYZ to their
employees because then the left can say
and we're all we're also going to ask
that companies do this and that and it
all becomes a kind of cultural level
battle rather than saying hey
Silicon Valley has gotten too strong
roll back its power government
regulation labor Etc
so I can sort of Follow that what that
means in commercial Enterprises let's
say you could boycott a company or
whatever but I don't quite follow how
you can do that with big Tech because
people don't want to boycott they want
to have their voice heard so how does
how would it work with big Tech
I mean with fake Tech I think uh
imposing common carrier requirements on
them they have to
um they have to be thought of as just
like your phone company right your phone
company doesn't yet I hope your phone
company can't uh
uh
uh censor you or refuse your service
um usually a train company can't refuse
to let you board based on your political
views and you I think that's the kind of
uh
that's the kind of mentality that should
be the regulatory framework for dealing
with big Tech and they would hate it
they would hate it but I think but it's
a kind of more material solution than uh
than I think we're saying
um
well what Republicans are pursuing now
which is to what what are they going to
do right now okay you saw the stuff that
musk published you're going to be a
little bit outraged about it what are
you really going to do and this is
something you're exploring in your new
book I understand the whole book is
about uh sort of the importance of
raising up countervailing power this is
a concept that emerged
um
do in the 20th century right where you
notice in markets where there's only two
or three sellers uh or two or three
buyers relative to many many other kind
of dual places
that kind of a situation uh naturally
the people who are subjected to the
original Power of those powerful
entities will kind of band together
whether it's in labor unions uh trade
associations this and that to protect
themselves but in some markets
government has to
um assist in that so then it takes a
little bit of political pressure
um and protection for for example trade
unionism
to succeed
um and that model was very helpful for
over that course of those 30 years we
had um a very prosperous economy uh an
Innovative economy a prosperous economy
but it just happened to be a little bit
fairer and the social distribution of
income was also less lopsided
or a new Breaking Up of the monopolies
into our police no well so not quite
because here's why I I for example on
Facebook and many other cases antitrust
I think doesn't necessarily doesn't
necessarily work because
um if you if you if you if you break
them up how are you going to break them
up people with their last names from
like
you know a to L would be in one network
and the other ones M to Z would be
another worker well everyone wants to
connect with everyone so in a way more
it's more rational for the big but the
big has to be subject to the
countervailing people power of people's
subject to Twitter Facebook Etc power
um so I think it just means government
restraining uh the ability for
censorship but bigness itself isn't
necessarily bad right again in the case
of railroads many car manufacturers etc
etc you actually want you want large
large is rational in many ways
as long as again other actors are
empowered to defend their interest to a
sufficient degree against these Giants
and when can we expect the book August
2023. well I look forward to it thank
you sir Robert Mari thank you so much
for taking the time to speak with us
today thanks Winston
[Music]
[Music]